in this video you're going to learn how
to do partial fraction decomposition
we're going to be going through all the
different types we're going to be
talking about linear factors repeated
linear factors quadratic factors
repeated quadratic factors as well as
improper fractions and a lot of the
different types are going through more
than one example so you get a lot of
experience with how to approach these
problems so let's get started with the
first example now what I want to show
you first is that you're familiar with
combining fractions so if you have you
know two fractions you want to combine
them into one fraction you know what do
you do well you want to get a common
denominator right so you get that common
denominator
combine these together and you've got it
right but what partial fraction
decomposition is is you're actually
doing that process in Reverse they're
giving us this fraction here and we want
to break it down to the two or three or
four or however many original fractions
that there were that would assemble to
give us this fraction here so the first
thing you want to do when you do partial
fraction decomposition is you want to
factor the denominator so if I do that
the tsunami would factor 2x minus 4
times X plus 1 and the numerator is 5x
minus 3 now again remember we're working
backwards we want to find out what those
original fractions were before you know
we assembled them okay into one fraction
with a common denominator so you can see
that you know one of the denominators
could have been X minus 4 one of the
denominators could have been X plus 1
now we don't want these fractions to be
improper meaning that the degree in the
numerator should be lower than the
degree in the denominator see how this
is actually the first that means this
must be a constant
a this is actually the first this must
be a constant B now we have to figure
out what those a and B values are and
the way we're going to do that is we're
going to clear the denominators we're
going to multiply through by the common
denominator so that we can more easily
solve this equation so the common
denominator multiply everything by X
minus 4x plus 1 so I'm going to
distribute that to the left and right
sides of the equation to keep it
balanced right and so if we do that when
you distribute here the numerator
denominator are going to cancel leaving
us with just 5x minus 3 over here you
can see the X minus 4s would cancel but
we have
a times X plus one over here when we
distribute you can see the X plus 1s
cancel and we just have B times X minus
four okay so are you with me so far so
we've cleared the denominators now
there's a couple different ways to do
this problem so let me see if I can show
you one technique first okay and then in
the second example I'll show you another
technique so the first technique I want
to show you is where you pick strategic
values for X now what do I mean by
picking strategic values for X so say
for example we let X equal negative 1
okay what happens when you let X equal
negative 1 is that's going to make this
0 times a is 0 this term is going to
cancel out now you can see you've got
negative 5 B if we put negative 1 in
here we get negative 5 minus 3 is
negative 8 so this way we can solve for
B by dividing both sides by negative 5
and you can see that B is equal to 8/5
okay similarly if we want to set X equal
to 4 let X equal 4 that's going to
cancel out this quantity 4 plus 1 is
going to give us 5 a which is equal to
20 minus 3 which is 17 and if we divide
both sides by 5 you can see that a is
equal to 17 fifths okay so you're with
me so far
so now what we want to do is we just
want to put these back into the original
fractions here so we have 17 fifths over
X minus 4 plus okay B was 8 fifths all
right over X plus 1 and then you can
take this a step further by you see how
you could factor out like a 1/5 so if we
did that this would be 1/5 times 17 over
X minus 4 plus 8 over X plus 1 and if
you combine these together you're going
to get back this original fraction right
here so that's example number one we're
going to do another example working with
these linear see linear just means
first-degree factors and let me erase
this board and we'll be I'll be back
with you okay example number two again
the first step is you want to factor
this denominator so if we do that we get
let's see 2x + 1 X and we get positive 5
and negative three so that gives us
negative 3x plus 10x which is 7x right
okay in the numerator is 6x minus 22 now
what we want to do is want to figure out
what were those original fractions
before we combine them we got this just
one fraction right so we're trying to do
the partial fraction decomposition and
so on what I'm going to do is I'm going
to write these linear factors linear
just means that they're to the first
degree like a line right but again we
don't want this to be an improper
fraction so if this is X to the first
this must be X to the zero meaning that
these are constants now you could put a
here and B here it doesn't really matter
but you want to make sure that these are
one degree lower okay so now what we're
going to do is we're going to do just
like we did in the last example we're
going to clear the denominators by
multiplying through by the common
denominator okay so if I take this and I
distribute it to each one of these
fractions we can clear the denominator
so 2x minus 3 times X plus 5 times this
one see the numerator denial just
leaving us with 6x minus 22 when we
distribute it to this one the 2x minus
3s cancel and we have a times X plus 5
and when we distribute to this one the X
plus 5s cancel so we have B times 2x
minus 3 sorry with me so far okay so now
I told you in the first example we could
pick strategic values for X so in this
example you know you could do negative 5
or you could do x equals 3 halves but
I'm going to show you a different method
here so what you're going to do here is
you're going to distribute and you're
going to collect like terms so you've
got a X plus 5 a plus 2 B X minus 3 B is
equal to 6 X minus 22 now if we collect
the X terms what you have is a X plus 2
B X you can't collect the constant terms
that's 5 a minus 3 B I'm going to factor
out the X here so that's going to give
us a plus 2 B times X and this is going
to give us 5 a minus 3 B and this equals
6 X minus 22 so now what we're going to
do is we're going to say all right the
coefficient in front of the X must be
equal to the coefficient on this side in
front of the X so that means that a plus
2 B is equal to 6 and the constant 5 a
minus 3 B
must be equal to negative 22 so all they
have to do now solve that system of
equations find our a and B put them back
in and these are going to be our partial
fractions that add up to the original
fraction okay so you're with me so far
so what I would do here is I'd multiply
this top equation by five so that's
going to give you five A plus ten B is
equal to 30 and if you combine those
together or let's I should say we
subtract those so 5 a minus 5 a is 0
negative 3 minus 10 is negative 13 B and
negative 22 minus 30 is negative 52
right so if we divide both sides by
negative 13 that comes out to be is
equal to 4 that worked out pretty nice
so if we put 4 back in to any one of
these equations I'll just put it into
this one here that's going to give us a
plus 2 times 4 is 8 equals 6 which means
that a is equal to negative 2 and then
the last step in sometimes students
forget this is that you want to put
these back in because you know one of
your classmates might have made this a
and this one B so your teacher wants to
see what are those you know actual
fractions okay so you want to write
those you know back in there so negative
2 times 2 X minus 3 plus B is 4 which is
4 over X plus 5 and if I really wanted
to be a little bit neater about this I'd
probably put the positive 1 first and
then subtract 2 over 2 X minus 3 now the
nice thing about partial fraction
decomposition is you could check your
work you could say well let me go ahead
and get common denominators combine
these into one fraction see if I get
back the original and that wouldn't be a
bad way just to practice to see you know
if you're on the right track so this is
working with the linear factors okay the
next one we're going to do is repeated
linear factors let me erase the board
and I'll be back with you okay in this
example we have what it's called a
repeated linear factor so linear means
it's to the first degree like a line
repeat you can see it's to a higher
power than one so it's going to be
squared or cubed and so on so what we're
going to do here is we're going to look
at this and say well the original
fractions could have had a denominator
of X minus 2 or X minus 2 squared right
so when you combine these together
what's the common
Ahmir if you had X minus 2 and X minus 2
squared well the common denominator
would be X minus 2 squared you would
have to multiply this fraction by X
minus 2 over X minus 2 so you have that
common denominator combine them together
right so what we're going to do now is
we're going to put a here and B here now
sometimes students get a bit confused by
this and they because they see that this
is x squared and they said well you told
us that you want this to be one degree
lower than the denominator well you're
just looking at the quantity that's
inside of the parentheses that's what
you want to be one degree lower so this
is X to the first this is X to the zero
it's a constant so we'll talk about
quadratic terms as we go through this
video okay but so these are going to be
our partial fractions but what we want
to do now is we want to clear the
denominators by multiplying through by
the common denominator so if I
distribute that to all of these okay
left and right side to keep the equation
balanced that's going to cancel out
these denominators okay one of these X
minus 2's cancels one of these is
leaving one left over and then here they
both cancel out so you just have B so
now you've got a couple of options here
I think what I'm going to do here is I'm
just going to pick I think maybe I'll
just distribute so this is just going to
be let's see a X minus two a plus B is
equal to 7x minus 11 so you can see that
a must be 7 right because the
coefficient in front of the X matches
the coefficient for the X over here so
that means that a is equal to 7 and then
over here we have an equation negative 2
a plus B is equal to negative 11 so
negative 2 a plus B equals negative 11
if we put 7 in for a that gives us
negative 14 plus B is equal to negative
11 add that 14 over and you can see that
B is equal to 3 so now we've got a and B
let's go ahead and rewrite our original
fractions here so 7 over X minus 2 plus
3 over X minus 2 squared and that's what
your teacher is going to want to see now
if you want to check your work you can
go ahead and get a common denominator by
multiplying these by you know X minus 2
over X minus 2 then you have a comment
on or combine them together and you
should get back 7 X minus 11 over that
common denominator so I'm going to raise
some more we're going to do another
example talking about repeated linear
factors
and okay example number two of the
repeated linear factors okay so what we
want to do remember is factor the
denominator first if you want to try
this one on your own go ahead and give
it a give it a go the first step though
here is I'm going to factor this
denominator by factoring out a greatest
common factor okay like so then we can
factor this a little bit further you can
see this is going to factor as X minus 3
the quantity squared and you can see
that's where our repeated linear factor
is coming in so let me go ahead and
rewrite this we've got 3x squared minus
24x plus 53 X all divided by the common
denominator or I should just say the
factored denominator and so what we want
to do now is we want to you know work
ourselves backwards and say well what
were those original fractions before we
combine them when we got this up here
right so you can see one of the
denominators could have just been X
right one of the fractions could have
had a denominator of X minus 3 and one
of the denominators could have had X
minus 3 squared so when you combine
these together what's the common
denominator it's x times X minus 3
squared so the key when you have a
repeated linear factor is you want to
include not just X minus 3 squared but
also X minus 3 to the first because when
you combine these together to get a
common denominator you're going to get
that X minus 3 squared so if you're
working backwards we don't know I mean
it's possible that this term could
actually be 0 you know and maybe we just
have this fraction in this fraction but
we won't know until we sort this out by
clearing the denominators and solving so
again our numerators are going to be a B
and C this time and again it's just one
degree lower that's X to the first so
that's going to be X to the 0 and so on
so let's go ahead and multiply through
by our common denominator which is going
to be this right here okay so if we
multiply everything by that common
denominator you're going to be left with
3x squared minus 24x plus 53 let's see
you didn't make a mistake this is plus
53 not supposed to be 53 X's plus 53
okay equals and this is going to be a
times X minus 3 squared okay because you
can see the X's are going to cancel one
another out plus B times X minus 3 plus
let's see also we have an X here right
and then over here we have plus CX okay
so we multiplied through by the common
denominator to clear the denominators
now we have a little bit something
easier to work with and what we can do
here is we can pick some strategic
values let's go ahead and do that method
for this one so let's just go ahead and
let I'll just put over here let X equal
zero okay so if we let a equal X equal
zero zero times anything makes this term
0 this term zero negative three squared
is nine a nine a this would be zero and
this would be 0 so you get 53 okay so if
we divide by nine you can see that
divided by nine you can see that a is
equal to 53 ninths not a super great
number but you know that's that's okay
that's just how that this particular
ones working itself out now let's say if
we do X is equal to three so let X equal
three if we do X equal to 3 that's going
to cancel out this term and this term so
we're going to end up getting 3c is
equal to well let's see what this side
is this would be 27 minus 3 times 24 is
how much let's see that's 72 right plus
53 okay so we've got some challenging
math here let's see if we can simplify
this ATS 80 minus 72 which is 8 right so
C is equal to 8/3 okay now we just have
to solve for B now what you might want
to do at this point there's nothing that
also we can cancel out by picking
strategic values just pick a small value
of x like let X equal 1 so if we let X
equal 1 let's see what does that give us
that gives us 3 minus 24 is negative 21
plus 53 is 32 all right and if we make
this equal 1 we get 1 minus 3 is
negative 2 Navy 2 squared is 4 4 times a
is going to give us let's see if what
would that be that'd be 4 times 50 3/9
which is 212 over 9 okay plus 4 minus
let's see 1 minus 3 is going to give us
negative 2 times 1 is negative 2
negative 2 B K plus negative 2
b-plus now we've got our C value which
let's see C we know is 8/3 times 1 so
that's 8/3 so then what you would do is
you would go ahead and solve for B and
then you know what a B and C are and you
want to put them back into those
fractions so this particular problem I
just made up off the top of my head some
of the numbers got to be a little bit
more challenging but I want to show you
the process so let's go ahead and get
into the next one working with quadratic
factors let me clean the board and I'll
be right back with you okay in this
example we're going to be working with
quadratic factors now you can see this
problem here it's already factored for
us but what we're going to do is we're
going to go ahead and break it up into
its two fractions your x squared plus 3
and X plus 5 okay so sometimes you have
to factor the denominator in this case
here to give it to us in factored form
but the question is now is what is the
numerator okay of these fractions well
this one's going to be a X plus B this
one's just going to be C now y ax plus B
well this is x squared so this always
wants to be one degree less if it was
the same degree or higher than that's
considered an improper fraction and
we'll deal with those as we move through
this video this one's actually the first
so this is just a constant that's X to
the 0 all we have to do now is clear the
denominators okay and solve for a B and
C and then we'll know what our original
fractions were before they became this
larger fraction okay so that's called
partial fraction decomposition so let's
go ahead and multiply through by the
common denominator it's a lot of
arithmetic and again you have to be
careful you don't make some simple
mistakes but if we distribute everything
okay this to every term left and right
size that's going to give us 6x squared
plus 21x plus 11 here the x squared plus
3s are going to cancel we have ax plus B
times X plus 5 right and then over here
we've got C times x squared plus 3 now
we've got a couple different options we
could do the strategic method where we
set X equal to negative 5 right that
would cancel out this term we can solve
for C and do it that method or we could
just foil this out collect like terms
and make a system of equation
I think I'm going to do the ladder
method so if we go ahead and distribute
and foil this out we get ax squared plus
five ax plus BX plus 5b plus CX squared
plus 3 C equals all this right we're
going to collect like terms so we've got
I'm going to collect the X Squared's
okay so that means a plus c times x
squared I'm going to collect the X terms
so that's going to be 5 a plus B times X
and then I'm going to collect the
constant terms 5b and 3c so 5 B plus 3 C
now you can see you can set these equal
to one another a plus C must equal 6 see
how you can set the coefficients in
front of x squared is equal so that's
one equation a plus C is equal to 6
we've got 5 a plus B is equal to 21
right and we've got 5 B plus 3 c 5b plus
3 C is equal to the constant 11 all we
have to do now is solve this system we
know our a B and C so should I go ahead
and do this well okay let's see so
what's the strategic way to do this well
let's see I think what I'm going to do
is I'm going to do a little bit of a
substitution technique I'm going to say
a is equal to negative C plus 6 so now I
know what a is I'm going to put that in
for a right here so that's going to give
us let's see 5 times negative C would be
negative 5 C right plus 30 plus B is
equal to 21 I clean this up a little bit
that's B minus 5 C is equal to negative
9 okay and then now we let's look at the
third equation we've got five B plus
three C equals 11 if we solve this by
multiplying the top equation by 5 or
maybe negative 5 negative 5 B plus 25 C
is equal to 45 if we add those together
you can see you're getting 28 C is equal
to 56 so that means that C is equal to 2
okay so now C is equal to 2 that means
that a is equal to 4 right a equals
for and if a is for that means that's 20
that means it B must equal one okay so
basically just solving a system of
equations but the last step but you want
to do is you want to put them back in so
your teacher knows what the actual
fractions are so that's 4x plus 1 over x
squared plus 3 right plus C which is
equal to 2 over X plus 5 now if you want
to check your work like always you can
go ahead and get a common denominator
combine these into one fraction and you
should get back that original fraction
that we started with here but this makes
it a lot easier to work with when you're
doing certain problems in calculus so
when you break it down you know these
are a little bit simpler and it's
they're easier to work with when you do
integration and other problems so I'm
going to erase this board when you do
another example with repeated quadratic
factors and then we'll keep going okay
example number two of the quadratic
factors I remember quadratic is a second
degree
they've already factored this
denominator for us then it makes it a
little bit easier but what we're going
to do here is we're going to work
backwards to figure out what those
original fractions were before we
combine them into this larger fraction
here so this is the partial fraction
decomposition process extra minus seven
can't be factored any further so this is
a quadratic factor our numerator is
going to be one degree lower ax plus B
now if this was an X cubed then what I
would have is ax squared plus BX plus C
so you want to start with ever this
degree is and then go descending until
you get to a constant if it was X to the
fourth you know and you couldn't factor
it it was like a quartic factor then it
would be ax cubed + BX squared plus CX
Plus D right so you start at a one
degree lower and you go down to the
constant this one's just linear X to the
first so this is going to be a constant
now make sure you pick different letters
you don't want to use the same letter
twice ok that's key also but what we
want to do here is we want to then clear
the denominators by multiplying by that
common denominator which is going to be
x squared minus seven times X plus one
if you distribute to each one of these
factors that's going to clear the
denominators and so that gives us 3x
squared plus 5x minus 4 minus
four equals ax plus B times X plus one
okay plus C times x squared minus seven
because you can see the X put X plus 1s
cancel each other out so I'm going to do
the same thing like I did on the last
one
because we've got you know more
variables it's a little bit more
complicated so what I'm going to do is I
think I'm just going to foil this out
and make a system of equations so if we
do that that's going to give us let's
see ax squared plus 8x plus BX plus B
plus CX squared minus seven C right and
that's equal to this right here and if
we collect like terms we get a plus c
times x squared plus a plus B times X
minus seven C right okay so now what we
can do is oh I forgot to be too nice so
plus B minus seven C so I - I'll scratch
this out so that's going to be let's see
plus B minus seven C okay so you want to
group the constants together so now we
can make a system of equations we've got
a plus C see how that's the x squared is
equal to three
right and then what else do we have
we've got a plus B is equal to five a
plus B is equal to five and we've got B
minus seven C B minus seven C is equal
to negative four okay so all we have to
do is solve this system and we'll know
what a B and C are we can put them back
into these original fractions and that's
our partial fraction decomposition so I
think what I'll do here is I'll subtract
these two equations here so a minus a is
0 then we get C minus B is equal to
negative 2 and so now we have negative 7
C plus B is equal to negative 4 I'm
going to add these two equations
together that's negative 6 C equals
negative 6 so you can see that C is a 1
if you put one back into any one of
these equations you can see a is equal
to two right and now we know a and C so
if a is 2 that means B must be 3 and
you've got your a B and C so all you
have to do is go ahead and put them back
into these fractions so this is going to
be 2x plus 3 right all over x squared
minus
seven plus C which is one over X plus
one and again you can check your work by
combining these together into by getting
common denominators combine them into
one fraction and should get back this
original fraction so let me erase this
board and we'll talk about the repeated
quadratic factors next and if you're
interested and you're preparing for the
SAT or that a CT or SAT I've got two
video courses available you feel free to
check those out I'll have links to them
in the description below this video we
go through a lot of different concepts
teaching example problems things that
you would typically see on the tests so
if you're interested in that check that
out if you're interested in online
one-on-one tutoring with me you can also
contact me about that mario's math
tutoring com or through the about page
on my youtube channel Mario's math
tutoring but let me erase this and we'll
go through the repeated quadratic
factors next okay now we're talking
about repeated quadratic factors and
again in this example they've already
factored the denominator for us if it
wasn't factored you would go ahead and
factor it first but you can see that x
squared plus 2 can't be factored any
further so this is a quadratic factor
but it's repeated see how it's to the
second power or if s to the third power
or to a higher power than one we have to
do is we have to consider what those
original fractions were with this
repeated quadratic factor so what our
fractions are going to look like they're
going to be x squared plus 2 but also x
squared plus 2 squared and we also have
this linear factor here which is X plus
3 okay so you're with me so far so
basically if you were to combine these
together all three of these you know
what's the common denominator well you
need 2 x squared plus 2 and you also
need an X plus 3 so if you were to get a
common denominator this one's missing
another x squared plus 2 and an X plus 3
so you have to consider that there could
be both of these terms or it could just
be this term this one might be equal to
0 we won't know until we solve this you
know this equation here so the numerator
though remember this is going to be one
degree lower so this is going to be ax
plus B this is going to be CX plus
this one is just going to be e because
this is a linear factor that's
first-degree this is a constant this is
second-degree so that's first degree
second degree first degree right she
wanted to be one degree lower and you
want to go in descending order to the
constant so it's possible that some of
these values ABCDE could be zero but we
won't know again until we solve this so
what we're going to do is we're going to
multiply through by the common
denominator this is the common
denominator so if we multiply everything
by this that's going to cancel so you're
going to get 3x to the fourth this one's
a big one this one so this is a monster
problem you can see they're getting a
little bit more difficult as we go
through this one here you're going to
have ax plus B right times what
well we cancelled out one of the x
squared plus two we're going to have
another x squared plus two as walls and
X plus three this one we're going to
have C X plus D okay times X plus three
right and then this one we're going to
have let's see e times x squared plus
two squared okay so this one is a it's a
monster it's a giant okay and so I don't
know if I'm any going to solve this one
for you guys but what I'm going to tell
you is that I would file this out
multiple this out I would collect like
terms and I would set that all the
coefficients in front of the X to the
fourth equal to three that would be one
equation then I would set all the X
cubes equal to negative two and so on
like we did in the previous example but
what I wanted to point out is that when
it's a repeated quadratic like this you
know you have to you know consider that
it could be expert plus two extra plus
two squared if this was x squared plus
two cubed then we would also have expert
plus two cubed you want to consider all
all those cases because we really don't
know you know what the original
fractions were before we combine them
and that's what we're doing we're
working backwards so I'm going to let
you do the arithmetic on this one send
me a text or not a text but send me an
email or a comment you know below if you
solve this you know let us know what
ABCD and E are let and what the partial
fractions are and I'm sure people that
watch this video will appreciate that
but what we're gonna do now is going to
talk about the improper fractions and
how to handle those so let me erase this
board and I'll be right back with you
okay the last type of partial fraction
position problem that we're going to
work with today is when you have an
improper fraction now how do you know
how to recognize an improper fraction
well that's when the degree okay the
power in the numerator is either the
same as the highest power term in the
denominator or greater okay sometimes
students don't realize that if this is
like actually the same like these are
both the same degree that that's
actually considered improper as well as
when the degree in the numerator is
greater than the denominator so what you
have to do in a situation like this is
do polynomial long division so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take x
squared minus 2x minus 3 see how many
times it goes in 2x cubed plus 0x
squared plus 0x plus 3 okay so
polynomial long division so x squared
goes into X cubed x times right so if I
distribute X I get X cubed minus 2x
squared minus 3x if you need a reminder
on how to do this polynomial long
division I have a video on it on my
Channel Mars math tutoring but I'm just
kind of doing this to show you this
process now how many times is x squared
going to 2 x squared that's 2 so if we
distribute we get 2x squared minus 4x
minus 6 we change the signs to the
opposite and add that gives us 7 X plus
9 but what do you do when you have the
remainder you put the remainder over the
divisor which is x squared minus 2x
minus 3 now what we want to do is we
want to do the partial fraction
decomposition on this remainder portion
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
factor the denominator X minus 3 and X
plus 1 and we're going to break this up
into its partial fractions so 7x plus 9
over X minus 3 X plus 1 and that's going
to equal let's see a over X minus 3 plus
B over X plus 1 okay so now all we have
to do is multiply through by the common
denominator which is X minus 3x plus 1
right if we distribute that to each term
we're going to get 7x plus 9 equals a
times X plus 1 plus B times X minus 3
and here I'm just going to pick
strategic values so if x equals negative
1 that's going to give you 2 because I'm
putting negative 1 for X that's going to
give us 0
that's going to give us negative 4b so
that means that B equals negative 1/2
and if I let X equal 3 that's going to
be what that's going to be 30 is equal
to 4a and this is going to cancel out
and give us 0 so that means that a is
equal to 30 force which is 15 halves now
all we have to do is put them back in
here so we've got let's see 15 halves
over X minus 3 let's see minus because
this is a negative 1/2 so minus 1/2 over
X plus 1 but you can see you can factor
out a 1/2 so this would be 1/2 times 15
over X minus 3 minus 1 over X plus 1 but
you also have X plus 2 so the idea here
is that if you were to add all this
together okay add all this together get
common denominators and so on you're
going to get back to this original
fraction but this is the partial
fraction decomposition we had to start
by doing the long division because the
degree in the numerator was the same or
higher than the highest power in the
denominator but then what we had to do
is we had to take the remainder okay
this fraction here and do the partial
fraction decomposition on it so I hope
this helped you to understand how to
work with partial fraction decomposition
better subscribe to the channel check
out more math videos on my mario's math
tutor YouTube channel and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon